tech giants are being criticized for the
role that false medical information may
have played in the recent measles
outbreak in the Pacific Northwest
congressman Adam Schiff sent a letter to
Google in Facebook last week asking how
they managed post from the anti vaccine
community Schiff said he is deeply
concerned about declining vaccination
rates and he asked for additional steps
to address the growing problem and we
reached out to Google and Facebook for
their comment goggle said that YouTube
which it owns is linking certain health
topics to third-party sources Facebook
said quote we've taken steps to reduce
the distribution of health related
misinformation on Facebook but we know
we have more to do we're currently
working on additional changes that we'll
be announcing soon always soon CBS News
contributors dr. Tara and Narula and
Nick Thompson editor-in-chief of Wired
magazine join us now Nick I'm gonna go
to you first here because this is
reminds me of the conversation we've had
about political misinformation it seems
like things that have feeling spread a
lot more quickly than things that are
filled with a lot of facts that is
absolutely that is the core of this
problem social networks are based on
emotion so content that makes us feel
emotional whether it's fear whether it's
uncertainty that spreads really quickly
so as they say a lie gets halfway around
the world before truth can get its boots
on science magazine made an interesting
point here they said false news was more
novel than true news and that's and
people were more likely to share it it's
more novel and there's also an asymmetry
where the people who are spreading
truthful information are reserved and
thoughtful and the people who are
passionate about misinformation are out
there just putting tons of stuff on the
internet so it's passion and there's an
asymmetry are you fighting terror that
your patients are more skeptical when
they come to your they come farm with
this is what I learned on the Internet
absolutely we see it very often you know
health information they say has now
become democratized which in a way is
good we want our patients to be educated
but certainly I think there's more of a
lack of trust in the medical profession
number one and number two people don't
always see their doctor as the final
authority they go to Google dr. Google
to get a second opinion they go there
because it's easy they're not gonna have
any judgment they don't have to pay a
copay and so and they don't have to make
a time for an appointment
but you know the
the issue is that we see this being a
very widespread not just relating to
vaccines but medications like statins
supplements that promote wellness and
anti-aging weight-loss anti-cancer or
cancer treatments that are alternative
and the issue is that you know some of
these misinformation can be kind of
ridiculous and maybe not so harmful like
taking a chocolate every day is going to
help your heart some can be good for you
well where do push-ups for tea for a
little misleading
some can be outright dangerous as we see
in the case with vaccines some in be
costly and some can just promote
unnecessary fear so what's a patient to
do well a patient should talk to their
doctor patient should be skeptical and I
also think one of the really important
lessons is that dr. Google can get
better the engineers can make the
internet a source of better information
by changing the way the algorithms work
but the algorithm makes them money in
its current form
so if feelings are what pay the salaries
everyone working at these tech companies
how can one doctor at a time really
overcome that well in the current
structure they do but it's also the case
that all of those people who work at the
tech companies they've gotten slammed in
the last year because of political
misinformation because of medical
misinformation because of all these
problems I actually think in the long
run if the only thing you were concerned
about was the bottom line of Silicon
Valley you would still change the
algorithms to get better medical
information out there you would still
send dr. Google to medicals Vitara where
do you go to get reliable medical news
so first foremost you can go to
government sites like the CDC or the NIH
and then you can look at associations
like the American Academy of Pediatrics
the American Heart Association American
Diabetes Association or reputable
universities then I think people can
really be trained to analyze what
they're reading so for example look and
see who the author is was this published
in a peer-reviewed journal who funded
this study who's benefiting from it was
it one study where you may not want to
base your decisions on it was it
multiple studies how many subjects were
studied a hundred or 500 thousand what
kind of trial an observational study not
the best or randomized control trial
much better to make your decisions on so
just this morning though we had a story
about doing 40 push-ups for men yes I
said for your heart so when you saw that
do you think that makes a lot of sense
you think I'd get out
that's where you really need to do your
digging right we in the media we love to
put out these sensational headlines and
it's unfortunate for people because they
see it and they may buy into it but
that's where you really have to look at
where it who's doing this study and
Union you need to go to a source that
can really break it down for you but
when you heard it dr. taryn a rule adage
it's a measures trying to figure out
whatever that number is I'm going to
google it and hopefully find some good
information can we just say that these
two were classmates at Stanford in the
same first time they've been on the
thing did you all date back in college
settle settle facebook says changes are
coming soon what's your over-under when
soon is I think they're probably working
hard on them right now right now all
right they do soon Tara thank you very
much thank you plus me